pout of dumb stories comes a great
lesson starts with the high school
student posting photos in her prom dress
on social media she's white and wore a
traditional Chinese dress this according
to the media sparks outrage over culture
appropriation first always be aware of
such BS stories like this are based on
some weenie faking offense and the media
breathlessly covers it because which is
suckers for outrage but as always the
cultural appropriation offense is a sham
the idea that it's racist to incorporate
something from another culture is so
morally bankrupt it's actually deadly
over time healthy people adopt practices
that enhance their lives meaning they
steal good things not the bad but all
things come from somewhere else so
appropriation isn't just a complement to
a culture it's how civilizations thrive
do you wear pajamas if you're not an
Indian Muslim you're racist the jam is
originated from Indian Muslims and God
forbid the sheets you sleep on are of
Egyptian cotton you eat yogurt that a
lot of social justice warriors do how
racist is that to appropriate the diet
of Central Asian herdsmen from 6000 BC
do you walk upright how dare you steal
the practice initiated by RT Pittacus
robinus the earliest hominid from
Ethiopia and some if you live your life
by avoiding cultural appropriation you'd
have no life whatsoever you didn't even
evolve at best you just be stupid which
is the trait found in all cultures and
stories generated by Twitter you know
this it's all started with some kid
named Jeremy he said my culture is not
your GD prom dress
you got 42 thousand retweets so that
makes it a story right that's how I was
going to say is that part of it is that
we are so we have become so dependent on
Twitter to actually help us figure out
what the news is cover stupid stuff like
this exactly exactly
poor girl she said I just thought it was
a beautiful dress I wanted to wear a
beautiful dress and she found it at a
thrift store vintage shop in Utah yeah
you know Jessie cultural appropriation
like imagine it
a miracle drug is made in Germany if you
are not from Germany she's I know I
can't take that drug it's from mother
that be appropriating their medicinal
expertise like if I wanted to wear
lederhosen and go to Oktoberfest
American can't do that perfect outfit
for you I would not want him to wear
lederhosen it's crazy that means those
crowd of crusty hippie white girls that
are liberals can't through the
dreadlocks the Rasta thing that means
black Americans can't wear English pea
coats there's a whole list of things you
can't or cannot do if you're gonna abide
by the strict rules of cultural
appropriation did this one time ever
come calm yet where the Little J Cruz US
jacket and shorts on outnumber yes that
was just bad fashion or appropriation
that was a mistake
what is there any example of cultural
appropriation that is actually real like
Oh an outrage an outrage I mean I can
understand individual mistakes at
Halloween something very that's very
stupid yes but the cultural
appropriation meaning like I'm wearing
you know a pea coat is British I
shouldn't be wearing that well I can
tell you one that just outraged me
recently let me show when you guys love
Kanye West radio near you the first
rapper was really David Bowie is that it
okay well he married a black woman right
yeah I see what I'm talking about but
you know I was very interested in this
because the idea that as Kimberly I
think was saying a moment ago you look
back at the Halloween thing and you get
a lot of the fraternities sororities
they get in trouble and they say they're
dressing up let's say like black people
or like they put on the sombrero and
they say we're dressing up for actually
May 5th that's coming up and they say oh
we're like Hispanic people hold on what
are you doing here it's not a matter of
making fun of us if you are part of it
right than understanding but I don't
think this young lady was making no
course not Chinese people with wearing
their I think she thought it was a nice
dress it's a beautiful dress I just
I think euro it's overdone well you know
I mean there's nice stores if you look
in the fashion market like Shanghai tank
that had really pretty dresses that are
celebrating the you know fashion the
tapestry the materials that are used to
make dresses I had very nice a black
dress kind of like that but that was you
know made this in silk and had a little
bit of a pattern on it so why wouldn't
you if it's she which wanted to choose
it because she thought it was a
beautiful dress and she wanted to have a
special night and look great I don't
know it's it's hard because people
impune motives and perhaps honor that
she was and I like it that this like it
seems like this generation of high
school students the women the young
girls are picking dresses that they
don't all look the same part of the
whole thing is to show more personality
and absolutism not just women the men
are picking dresses what do you make of
the fact that she made the prayer
gesture God was that a little bit much
no no no it's fine the villain in this
whole thing is the person who tweeted
and Tritan because he knew that the
outrage he wasn't really even mad he
just knew would get picked up and end up
on a successful show like the violent
screaming inside please don't post